James Montgomery says how can you be
confident and courageous if your father
was emotionally absent and narcissistic
I'm 21 and very creative my mother is a
people pleaser who isn't confident and
herself and uses me as emotional support
help well look you're confident about
some things you said you were very
creative so you're confident enough to
say that and you know you I don't see
the problem with questions like this I'm
not criticizing your question by the way
is that you're linking your lack of
confidence and courage to the absence of
your father and his narcissism and also
associating it with your mother being a
people pleaser so and you know there may
be something to that
it could be James that you could could
stand to talk to somebody
you know for a while on a regular basis
and see if they can help you sort this
out you obviously seem to think that
this is a problem with you moving
forward in your life if you don't want
to talk to someone about it then I would
say the other thing you need a plan I
know I always refer to that but it's the
case you need a plan and then you need
to break the plan down into this into
small steps that are somewhat
challenging that you have a high
probability of nonetheless obtaining and
then I would say by observing yourself
move forward properly that your
confidence will increase you're only 21
you know so you know what that old but
that's the best I can do without having
more information about the specifics of
your situation